[Music]
your boys must think you're the coolest
mom freed you to go to stuff like this
are they here tonight have fun they are
coming tonight and they are excited and
it was kind of last minute so that makes
it even more exciting you know nummies
so they're on their way now they send me
pictures that are outfits and I'm
excited well the voice is nominated
tonight if you do get slimed what is the
plan for this outfit are you okay what's
you know what I'm okay with that I'm
okay with that I feel like I've already
got it captured right now you're
capturing it so I'm good you and Blake
how do you guys handle the relationship
with being on the show you know what I
feel like when we were coming back this
season I was a little nervous I was like
this is gonna be weird but it's been you
know the show is so real it's all it is
is us just being there and being us and
you know those days you're shooting some
of the stuff I've seen that they've
aired I'm like like I don't even
remember doing that because you're just
there all day being you and then they
capture it and they edit it and you're
like whoa like that happened so it's
been really fun obviously like any I
don't anytime I can be around Blake is
is you know a blessing so as much time
as possible they're gonna kill me if I
don't ask you any new music coming up
anything in the work that's a really
good question I actually was in the
studio last week can you - I'm not gonna
tell you why but I was in the studio I
felt really good I sound ready for me is
the number one like that's the thing
that really gets me like that's when I'm
like yes like I feel alive but I love
doing it and I'll always make music if
someone lets me
[Music]